[Música]
estas personas que recorren las calles
están cazando pandilleros en Puerto
Príncipe desde hace meses la capital de
Haití está bajo el control de pandillas
que tienen aterrorizada a la población
algunos habitantes desesperados han
empezado a perseguir a los miembros de
estos grupos armados para matarlos
suelen ir armados con machetes palos y a
veces acompañados Por la policía
este movimiento de autodefensa fue
bautizado huacale y nació el 24 de abril
en el barrio canapé tras un ataque
perpetrado por pandillas nuestro
observador vive muy cerca de allí y
quiso permanecer en anonimato por
razones evidentes de seguridad vivo a
300-400 metros de canapé y el lunes 24
de abril hoy muchas explosiones fuertes
tiroteos durante toda la mañana
después una amiga de canapés me contó
que la policía y la población habían
interceptado un minibús en el que iban
14 chicos jóvenes armados y con
municiones etcétera
en estas imágenes aficionadas se ve que
los detenidos siguen moviéndose y
parecen temer por sus vidas les pusieron
neumáticos cerca
luego la población irrumpió para
ejecutarlos para quemarlos
New Willy
tras este suceso el movimiento huacales
se extendió a otros barrios de Puerto
Príncipe Y también a otras ciudades del
país entre el 24 de abril y el 4 de mayo
pasados nuestra redacción identificó al
menos 18 incidentes en los cuales fueron
asesinadas personas que presuntamente
estaban vinculadas a estas pandillas en
total varias decenas de personas
terminaron sin vida hosi august ducena
es responsable de programas en la red
Nacional de defensa de los Derechos
Humanos en Haití y esto nos cuenta no es
solo una casa de pandilleros armados
sino también de cualquier persona de la
que se sospeche que tiene vínculos con
estos delincuentes por ejemplo hemos
visto casos de mujeres que han sido
linchadas porque supuestamente estaban
en una relación con estos delincuentes
en el movimiento
la población lanzó contra los
pandilleros sus parejas también deben
ser castigadas Nadie puede salir impune
desde hace varios años la población se
enfrenta a la violencia de los
pandilleros que gozan de la protección
de las autoridades estatales los
pandilleros Implicados En masacres
ataques armados secuestros para pedir
rescate nunca son buscados por la
policía
ni son perseguidos por la justicia para
ser juzgados y condenados por los
delitos de los que se les acusa Así que
la población está harta
según nuestros observadores el
movimiento
puede ser la solución a los problemas
del país e incluso podría empeorar la
situación para la red Nacional de
defensa de los Derechos Humanos la
población no debe jugar el papel de la
policía y hacer justicia por mano propia
sobre todo por los riesgos que esto
puede conllevar
en general las personas que son
linchadas son sometidas a
interrogatorios muy breves y luego son
simplemente asesinadas
esto significa que son personas a las
que no se les respeta el derecho a las
garantías judiciales
lo segundo es que existe un enorme
riesgo de cometer errores de que
personas inocentes sean asesinadas por
no haber dado las respuestas correctas
para preservar sus vidas
un error es lo que parece haber ocurrido
el pasado 29 de abril en el norte del
país ese día
hacerle un favor a su padre y se
desplazó en mototaxi y en el camino fue
detenido junto con un amigo y enviado a
la estación de policía de la misma
localidad según explica su padre mattheo
Ezequiel
decidieron enviarlos a gross donde les
revisaron los teléfonos y lo que
llevaban en la maleta
solo encontraron una vela y un
encendedor nada sospechoso ningún arma
después la policía dejó entrar a la
estación a dos individuos para que se
encargaran de ellos y lo sacaran
[Música]
los mataron los decapitaron y luego
quemaron los cadáveres
mataron a un hombre Inocente acusándolo
de ser un Pandillero
mal orbe era mi cuarto hijo murió a los
28 años
[Música]
mientras el movimiento wakale parece
estar perdiendo fuerza los líderes de
las pandillas han amenazado a la
población con represalias por nuestra
parte activamos nuestro modo
las armas hablan al sur de Puerto
Príncipe las pandillas ya han asesinado
a varias personas como venganza y por su
parte el Primer Ministro Ariel esperó
hasta el primero de mayo pasado para
pronunciarse sobre el movimiento buakale
Aunque desde el 24 de abril ya se
cometían asesinatos a diario les pido a
los habitantes no hacer justicia por
mano propia y colaborar con la policía
hasta aquí esta investigación realizada
por Chloe vernier periodista del equipo
de los observadores si usted también
desea informar a nuestro equipo sobre un
suceso todos nuestros contactos aparecen
en pantalla hasta la próxima semana